[Musique]
nouvelle étape dans la fusion des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine les élus des deux
collectivités ont voté au sein de leurs
assemblées respectives
la transformation d'activité en une
agence inter départemental d'insertion
alors pour décrypter ce sujet nicolas
landry bonsoir bonsoir grégory de la
rédaction de tv 78 qu'est ce que ça
change concrètement cette transformation
c'est la dernière étape l'aboutissement
de la politique inter départemental
d'insertion des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
lagence activity va dorénavant s'occuper
des deux territoires en proposant des
dispositifs de retour à l'emploi au
public chinois et au public à dos et
quan et les habitants des hauts de seine
mais rappelez-vous grégory cette
démarche de mutualisation des outils de
politique d'insertion avait déjà
commencé en septembre 2018 avec
l'adhésion des eaux tiennent à activity
puis en mars 2010neuf avec
l'inauguration d'une plateforme commune
jobs 92 et job 78 un site internet
regroupant regroupant des offres
d'emplois sur les deux territoires
ce rapprochement se poursuit en vue
peut-être d'une éventuelle fusion est ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler ce qu'est
activity activity c'est une agence
d'insertion créé par le conseil
départemental des yvelines ans en 2015
sa priorité la réinsertion par l'emploi
des personnes en situation de précarité
ce peut être les bénéficiaires du rsa
dont le département s'occupe les
chômeurs de longue durée ou les
populations des quartiers politique de
la ville son objectif accompagner ces
personnes en leur proposant un parcours
de retour à l'emploi
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
concrètement comment ça se passe alors
cette agence développe différents
dispositifs pouvant aider à la
réinsertion
un retour directement à l'emploi prises
en charge par le département
vous savez qu'il a différentes
compétences notamment dans les collèges
c'est aussi organiser des événements un
peu innovant comme un match de football
entre recruteurs et demandeurs d'emploi
qui a été organisée à guyancourt donc
des choses plus originales
l'idée en fait le coeur d'activité
d'activité c'est de penser d'innover
dans les démarches de retour à l'emploi
et c'est aussi l'orientation de
personnes vers des formations vers des
secteurs plus tôt intentions les
secteurs en tension ce sont des secteurs
font du mal à recruter le btp le
numérique ou le service à la personne
dans le département des yvelines mais
c'est aussi le cas dans les
hauts-de-seine et pour cela qu'il est
inondée partenariat avec saint quentin
en yvelines par exemple des
collectivités avec des structures de
formation comme l'école de la nouvelle
chance et des entreprises directement
aussi qu'ils recherchent des des
personnes à employer si on fait un bilan
de l'année 2018 plus de 4000 yvelinois
accompagné près de 1800 repris une
activité 6 ans sont en formation et
depuis sa création en 2016
lagence a permis à 5000 yvelinois de
retrouver un emploi ou une formation
qualifiante
merci nicolas pour ce point
d'information et donc une nouvelle étape
de franchie dans cette fusion lancé
depuis 2016 entre le département des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine